تحولت المعارك حول بخموت التي تقع على بعد
15 كيلو مترا من مدينه سوليدار الى ما
اطلق عليها طرف النزاع مفرمه لحم اذ باتت
حرب استنزاف وحشيه تحصد ارواح الاف الجنود
يوم الجمعه اعلنت موسكوبتها على سردار في
الشرق الاوكراني وهو ما تصرك يفعلنفه
ويؤكده
المسائيه الجمعه ان المعارك الطاحنه لا
تزال تدور في هذه البلده الصغيره المعروفه
بمناجم الملح علينا جميعا ممارسه المزيد
من الضغط
من اجل ما يشبه حياه عاديه في الوقت الذي
يفتقرون فيه لان وسائل العيش بما في ذلك
الماء والكهرباء في ظل قصف روسي مستمر وفي
مدينه سيفريس كال واقعه على بعد 25
كلمدار ترددت اصوات المدفعيه يوم الجمعه
ما زاد من قلق السكان الذين باتوا يستعدون
للاسود
لا شيء جيد في صيدليه
اكثر من مره انه امر مخيف
نحن خائفون ولكن اين نذهب نامل فقط ان لا
يتراجع الجيش الاوكراني اصبحت هذه المدن
القريبه من خط الجبهه مازوله تقريبا بعد
قطع شبكات الهاتف فضلا عن صعوبه
وسائل النقل العام